all right so the next stop will be uh by
yang zhong on fundamental limits
uh okay so good everyone everyone so my
name is ian juhan and i'm
currently a postdoc at sms institute and
before that i obtained my phd at sample
double yield just last summer so the
title of my talk will be fundamental
image of learning in data driven
problems so what does this title mean
so the motivation of this talk is that
so keep so in many practical
learning or decision making problems we
have some data and will find the problem
and we'd like to find out what is the
optimum method to trade off between
real-world resources or to take good
care of the practical constraints
so basically this house can't decom
compo could be decomposed into two parts
the first one is that we like to
understand the fundamental limits what
the value is the photonics problem yeah
and on the other hand would like to
exploit the key structure of that
problem to give us new technical or
algorithmic insights
so okay let's take a look at a very
quick yeah just a motivating example
so consider the problem of dynamic
assortment optimization which is
actually very common in online retailing
problems where the website aims to
select a subset of substituted items to
the user to maximize the expected
revenue so this is a very classical
problem in let's say revenue management
and
so why fundamentally miscounts matters
in that problem
so there has been a rich line of
research on that problem for example the
overall at all in 2017 shows that under
the specific environment yeah by
stochastic identity just means that the
user's your value function will be fixed
across time so basically in that setting
actually a small regret could be
achievable basically if the seller could
obtain a
rep rate could attain the optimal
revenue in hindsight
so then this environment could be
extended to more complex environments
such as the contextual ones where the
seller's value is the used value could
actually depend on some context or some
robust environment because yeah it could
be some there could be some adversary
and it turns out that okay under those
environments actually a small regret
could still be achievable but the
remaining question is that okay then why
not just consider them um
also a more natural choice basically the
adversarial environment basically okay
suppose that the values would change
across time in actual way and a positive
result zero would actually subsume some
of the results in the previous one
so last year we took a look at this
problem and turns out that yeah the
difficulty in the other zero environment
is precisely dictated by the mean
whether the mean reward function is a
low degree polynomial or not so this
result is actually if and only the
result so specializing to the assortment
organization problem the mean reward
function looks like v over y minus 3
which is not a polynomial so yeah using
this result we know that
the gram must be large
so this is just a quick example it just
tells us two different usefulness of the
fundamental limits so first it will tell
you a practitioner or researcher what
can be achieved and what cannot and by
looking at the problem we'd like to
diagnose the key difficulty and find
necessary structure for this problem to
be solvable
so okay we i don't have many times much
time so i will actually just do a quick
overview of some of the problems i
did on fundamental limits so yeah this
we will have three examples in different
communities and the first example is
actually
the non-parametric antibiotic problem
the problem is actually very simple
suppose we have an id observations from
underlying density supported on the
units tube and i would like to a to
estimate the entropy of this density
looking like the integral of minus f log
f
so that problem has a lot of
applications and has been long studied
let's say in both the statistics and
information theory literature there is a
rich line over prior research and they
propose a lot of estimators either based
on kernel-based method or nearest
neighbor-based method
so
what should what yeah what did i do here
so the major drawback in this line of
research is that actually typically they
rely on a prevalent assumption that the
density is actually lower bonded by a
positive universal constant say yeah the
density is always a lower 25.01
everywhere
so why do they make this assumption this
is because that the map from t to minus
t log t is actually a non-smooth
function near zero so this is actually a
technical condition not driven by
practical needs and so our question is
that then what is the fundamental effect
of small densities in that problem would
that actually make the problem harder or
even impossible
it turns out that yeah even under
without any assumption on the density
lower bound we could still obtain a new
minimum risk using of entropy estimation
so we are assuming that this density is
s or the smooth on d dimension and you
will have earned samples actually the
minimum exact minimum space it could be
written like this
so here both the upper and the lower
bounds are actually new and that
actually just dictates what is the
fundamental effect of small domains
because of small densities
and for interestingly especially for the
upper bound actually we need to employ a
new
two-stage approximation idea basically
the each from h of f is our target and
in on the first stage we need to
approximate the density by a smoother
one and on the second stage we need to
approximate but the functional well
another smaller chosen carefully and
using this tuesday of preparation
actually we could take good care of the
small densities and achieve the minimum
risk yeah dictated above
so yeah so let's also take a quick look
at the second example which is a theory
of the profile mle yeah if you have
attended clearance talk this morning he
also talked about mle and this is
actually a joint work with him
so
the philosophy of maximum likelihood is
arguably the most commonly used
philosophy in statistics yeah dating
back to jonathan in oh yeah in 1912 and
this is fundamental method of parameter
estimation with numerous successes the
idea is actually very simple suppose we
have a random variable x following some
parametric fact distribution then the
mue is just the estimator which
maximizes the likelihood of the
probability of observing x under p theta
and the appeal of maximum likelihood
actually stems from its universal pretty
good mathematical properties and a good
check record as a tour in applied
statistics a record accumulated over 50
years yeah in the year that's it yeah
quoted by elfrun in the year of 1980 and
now it's actually over 100 years of
heavy usage
now what goes wrong with the typically
mle the idea here is that in modern
applications actually the vanilla mle
fails to capture some in various
properties the structure in our problem
suppose that actually our problem has
some grouping bank structure dictated by
group action ge this suppose our target
integrates invariant up yeah up to
the group actions
then a sufficient statistic for us is
that yeah suppose we observe some of
region x actually we could consider the
equivalence class yeah under this
projection and take these only take
exits as our
observation so that actually motivates
us to let's say to propose what is what
we mean by likelihood of a profile
basically this is just the probability
of observing such a profile yeah summing
over all observations with that profile
and along this key in 2004 proposed the
id of the profile mle or the pmle in
short basically this is just the
disaster level mre maximize the
likelihood of the observation the pmi
just maximizes the likelihood of the
giving profile
the questions okay so
yeah so the pmle was invented let's say
for more than 17 or 18 years and there
are many statistical questions left for
this quantity basically okay is there an
analog analogy between mle and pmle and
how to analyze it and okay because the
motivation of pmre is to estimating
group invariant targets so is pmle
actually cdc or people
and a more subtle question is that
okay if pmle were also subject to
certain limitations as well
so our contribution here is that we
actually we were able to provide the
title statistical analysis for the pmle
under the specific yeah discrete
distributed model and on the group
transformations basically we showed that
yeah
so for the first question yes mle is
really optimal in primary estimation and
the primary is actually optimal in group
invariant parameter estimation and for
the quest first second question is that
we need to use a novel analysis called
the competitive analysis to analyze the
statistical property of pmle instead of
the zero order of first order idea of
analyzing the burden of mle
and for the third question is that yeah
it's actually universally true so
basically no matter what your group
environment target is you could simply
plug in the pml estimator but with the
additional condition that when the
packet iron is large and
what about that condition is violated
actually yes the pmle will subject to
certain limitations and we are able to
quantify both the exact penalty and also
where is the threshold for the target
edge basically it's n to the power minus
one third well it's a sample size
so this actually just provides a
complete picture let's say understanding
for the pmle for this part
and the last part yeah more applied part
is that here recently i also took a look
at the learning to build in first price
auctions and this motivation is that
there is a recent industrial shift from
second price to first prices auctions
for online display ads such as including
many ad exchanges such as advances in
the exchange open apps and google and
even several months ago google
in addition to display at google also it
was moving adsense which is their online
contextual ad platform to first press
auction
and there are several reasons for this
shift but this is not our focus our
focus is actually the challenge brought
forth to the bidder by that
industrial shift so the question is that
okay now in first place options how to
beat
okay
and
yeah the principle of first production
is actually pretty easy so the optimal
bid is nothing but just the solution to
this importantization program yeah
that's for a single bid basically yeah
the bidder has a private value and yeah
they would like to maximize the extra
utility times the probability that
she will win the auction is greater than
other maximum bid
but there are many problems let's say
in practice for example first thing he
said we'll never know yeah what is that
probability so we need to this requires
some learning process and this problem
is actually some it was some non-linear
reward you have the action space is also
continuous and in practice we can hardly
make any distribution assumption on
private value or other speed even id
assumption is somehow is not okay for us
and
the third thing here is that the
feedback structure might be censored we
might may not be able to see and yeah in
is food and analytic it could be binary
it could be one sided sensor feedback
and so on so on and if we would like to
test it as a bandit or online learning
problem we need to compete with a strong
time-varying oracle we cannot yeah
compete with a chevy oracle site yes
which pays less
it be the same price over time so
basically those are the challenges in
this problem from the technical side and
our result here is that under yeah many
settings actually this optimal regret
could be efficiently achievable for a
single bead yeah and the the crux here
is to make use of the structure special
structure first price auctions including
its revolt function and the feedback
structure and a very interesting thing
here is that there is actually an
interplay between the rules function the
figure structure in the sense that okay
yeah
neither of these alone could provide us
less it could lead to the rhythm of with
optimal regret and proof and they
actually probably failed to
give the optimal regret there
and in addition to the theoretical
results we also so our b we propose a
beating algorithm and it is also
completely deployed by verizon media dsp
and we will run their our algorithms on
their data so basically this is a curve
yeah yeah it basically is a
function of the cumulative rewards over
time and the red curve is basically yeah
the performance of l over algorithm so
the takeaway is that actually yeah our
algorithm performs very well on many
different data sets possibly with
different natures
so
yeah in addition to those examples and i
also like to plot some of my other works
but but they have a common thing
actually they have two common things by
the learning and detective problem the
second thing is about optimality yeah i
studied something like yeah bandits with
limits around infection yeah how to
predict markov chains distributed
failure learning and some ongoing work i
will also include some smooth online
learning some application not in a
bandage
the nail pricing and so on so
yeah if i would like to use two words to
summarize myself then use my best place
one is optimality and the other is this
interdisciplinary and i'm very i'm super
happy to talk to many great people here
over many great problems thank you
next we have chris telling us about
randomized controls